what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
have some pretty big spider-man no way
home news today
we're getting pretty close to the movies
release date and hopefully getting
pretty close to that trailer releasing
and as we get closer and closer
more leaks are going to inevitably get
out and today we actually have some
pretty good leaks we have some leaks
about
three different scenes that are going to
be taking place during spider-man no way
home
two of those involving some pretty cool
rematches that i know
a lot of fans are going to be really
excited to see then one
new fight that of course fans are going
to be excited for as well
we also have one leak that gives us more
confirmation that toby maguire
spider-man will be in the movie
and then it looks like we might actually
have a time frame for when to
expect the trailer like i said a lot to
dive into today so let's get into it but
if you're new be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
so before diving into a scene that toby
maguire is going to have in spider-man
no way home
let's talk about something that has
happened recently that gives us further
evidence that he
is indeed going to be in this film toby
maguire's spider-man spanish
voice dub actor roger pera has seemingly
confirmed that he is going to be working
on spider-man no way home
on instagram he was recently asked if he
was going to be dubbing toby spider-man
again
in which he replied with sort of a
two-part answer one he zipped his lips
but then he gave us a thumbs
up seemingly confirming that yes he is
going to be dubbing toby spider-man
again
now this is actually his second
confirmation of him stating that he is
going to be dubbing toby for spider-man
no way home
in fact last time it looked like he kind
of got into some trouble for saying
anything about it
earlier this year in april he was
interviewed by a youtube channel
el sotondo planet in which they asked
him a similar question
if he is going to be working on any
spider-man film soon in which he
responded that he was indeed going to be
working
on a film soon this was posted to their
youtube channel in which
very shortly after the part where he
answers this question
was removed it was edited out which
youtube does allow you to do once a
video was posted you still can edit
things out so today isn't the first
confirmation we've got from him but the
second
and of course it's just more evidence of
toby being in the film because
if he's not in the film why would his
spanish and portuguese voice actor be in
the film
especially because he doesn't do the
work for tom holland spider-man or
andrew garfield spider-man
just toby's so more evidence that toby
maguire is going to be in the film and
of course that also gives us more
evidence
that andrew garfield will be in the film
as well and speaking of those two
like i mentioned in the beginning we
have some leaks today involving the two
of them and our own tom holland
spider-man
now there seems to be a common theme
with several of the leaks that have come
out pretty recently
and i have heard from some people and
some people have been posting online
recently
that there is a pretty big plot leak out
there that is
true specifically one part and that
specific part is about doctor strange
somehow
capturing the villains from the other
universes and keeping them in some sort
of a magical prison inside of the
sanctum
from there apparently doctor strange and
tom hall and spider-man will have a bit
of a disagreement
this disagreement is presumably about
doctor strange
keeping these villains locked up and
from here it seems like our peter parker
is going to be responsible for
releasing these villains now how tobey
maguire spider-man and how andrew
garfield spider-man get into the picture
that's still unclear whether doctor
strange brings them in for help or the
multiverse somehow sucks them out of
their own universes and spits them out
into ours
we're not sure about that yet but we
know that they're going to be in our
universe somehow
and thanks to the account superhero
theorists that i've mentioned on here
before we have a little bit of insight
on a few scenes that we can expect from
toby maguire spider-man andrew garfield
spider-man and our very own
tom holland spider-man according to
superhero theorist we are going to be
getting
three fight scenes and two of these are
going to be rematches from previous
movies
the first one of course is going to be
toby maguire's peter parker and
doc ock we had some pretty amazing
iconic
fights in spider-man 2 specifically that
train scene and it looks like we're
going to be getting at least
one more iconic fight between them as
well then according to this report we
are also going to get a rematch between
andrew garfield's peter parker and
electro now these two are the fights
that we
kind of knew were going to happen after
all the first characters confirmed to be
in this movie
outside of the normal cast of tom
hollands and deya jacob battle on
etc were alfred molina and jamie foxx
and both of them weren't exactly quiet
about it they pretty much came out and
stated it
now to their defense the reports did
come from major trades like deadline and
variety but jamie foxx did post a
picture to his instagram about the
spiderverse and alfred molina in an
interview basically gave
how he enters our universe away giving
us a lot of details including on when
exactly he's going to be taken from his
universe and according to him what
director john watts told him
is that one nobody ever really dies in
the marvel universe and two they were
going to take him right from that water
scene at the end
just before he dies which means we can
probably assume that jamie foxx's
electro is going to be taken from the
end of the amazing spider-man 2 right
before he dies
but then superhero theorist says that
we're going to have another showdown and
that's going to be with
our peter parker tom holland and an
amazing spider-man character
now at this point in time so many
characters have been rumored to be in
this film we're not exactly sure who
they could be referring to but we do
know two things
one is that there's essentially going to
be a sinister six
in this movie a sinister six consisting
of villains from
all of the universes not just ours not
just from the spider-man samurai
universe and not just from the amazing
spider-man universe but all of them
combined the three different spider-men
will team up together to fight the
sinister six
and the main villain behind it all is
going to be the green goblin
and based off of everything that we've
heard so far the green goblin is going
to be willem dafoe's green goblin
from the sam raimi spider-man universe
he is seemingly going to be the leader
of the sinister six and there's also
rumors that we could actually have
our own norman osborne appear in the
movie as well and he could actually be
good there has been a leak and although
this isn't one of those leaks that has
been confirmed to be true
it does state that the other norman
osborne from the sam raimi universe is
going to kill
our norman osborne and if that were to
come true that could have
huge implications for the future of our
marvel cinematic universe
especially if we've learned anything
from loki and i don't think that the tva
is going to be around for much longer to
correct things
and speaking of like i mentioned in the
beginning it looks like we may have a
time frame of when to expect the
spider-man no way home trailer
and this is also coming from superhero
theorist who has never actually
mentioned anything about a trailer
release date before but somebody tweeted
i'm guessing the trailer is coming
before the premiere of what if and he
responded with oh yeah before that now
what if comes out on
august 11th so if this is true it's
going to be coming out before that which
means we have
less than a month but if we think about
this this actually makes a lot of sense
and we should have seen this from the
beginning
the loki series is what's really
introducing the multiverse to us
and more than likely in just a couple of
days now the show is most likely going
to end
with the tva being taken down and
destroyed the tva was responsible for
killing essentially
branch timelines basically their job is
to prevent the multiverse
and with the loki finale most likely
ending with the tva out of the picture
for good
that's going to set up spider-man no way
home and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
and this is what needs to happen before
we see the spider-man no way home
trailer
that way people could have a good grasp
on what the multiverse actually is
and that way variants of a character
aren't really that confusing
i mean we've seen at least 20 loki's by
now so seeing three spider-man on screen
shouldn't be that big of a deal
although it's going to be the biggest
deal ever but thanks to loki
people shouldn't be confused so if this
report is true about the trailer coming
out before what if
on august 11th it makes perfect sense
because loki had to finish
first let's just hope it's true but let
me know what you think about all of
these leaks
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe and hit
the notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me